O
LEAVE AFGHANISTAN.
>> THIS MAY BE THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGE SO FAR OF THE SEVEN
MONTHS OF JOE BIDEN'S
PRESIDENCY.
HOW TO KEEP THAT COMMITMENT TO
AMERICANS AND AFGHAN ALLIES THAT
WANT TO LEAVE EVEN NOW THAT
THERE ARE NO LONGER TROOPS IN
AFGHANISTAN AND DEALING WITH ONE
CRISIS FROM ANOTHER TO THE
RAGING PANDEMIC TO PEOPLE
WITHOUT POWER IN THE STIFLING
HEAT IN THE WAKE OF HURRICANE
IDA TO THE POLITICAL PUSH BACK
FROM AFGHANISTAN.
REPUBLICANS ARE OUTRAGED WITH
THE HANDLING OF EXIT ESPECIALLY
IN A SO-CALLED FREEDOM CAUCUS.
YET, THEY SUPPORT THE FORMER
GUY, THE ONE WHO SENT ALL OF
THIS IN MOTION IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
THE HYPOCRISY IS OFF THE CHARTS,
AND IT IS SICKENING.
AND IT'S NOT LIKE IT 'S THE FIRT
TIME.
THEY ARE ALL ABOUT CRITICIZING
JOE BIDEN FOR LEAVING AMERICANS
AND ALLIES BEHIND.
>> I GO TO BED AT NIGHT AND WAKE
UP DURING THE NIGHT AND WAKE UP
IN THE MORNING THINKING ABOUT
THE FAMILIES THAT LOST LOVED
ONES OVER THERE AND IN ADDITION,
THE AMERICANS WE LEFT, THE
ALLIES WE ABANDONED, THE
CHRISTIANS THAT WILL BE
MURDERED, TORTURED AND MURDERED
AND THE WOMEN AND GIRLS.
>> BUT THEY DON'T WANT THOSE
ALLIES COMING INTO THE UNITED
STATES.
>> FORMER INTEL THAT ARE TELLING
ME PEOPLE THAT ARE BEING BROUGHT
IN HERE, THERE IS A SIGNIFICANT
PERCENTAGE THAT ARE FUTURE
BOSTON MARATHON BOMBERS BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT DOING ADEQUATE
VET
VETTING.
>> DO YOU SEE THE RIDICULOUSNESS
IN THAT, RIGHT?
AND WHAT'S THE LOGIC HERE?
ARE THEY ALLIES OR BOSTON
MARATHON BOMBERS?
MAKE UP YOUR MIND.
YOU'RE UPSET BECAUSE YOU LEFT
PEOPLE BEHIND AND THEY'RE
BRINGING BUT THE ONES WHEN YOU
GET THEM OUT AND BRING THEM
OVER, THEY'RE FUTURE BOSTON
MARATHON BOMBERS?
THEY CAN'T REALLY SEEM TO
DECIDE.
MAKES NO SENSE.
AND THEN THERE IS OF COURSE
KEVIN McCARTHY ALL IN FAVOR OF
THE FORMER GUYS PLAN TO
WITHDRAWAL TROOPS FROM
AFGHANISTAN BUT NOW THAT
PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS ACTUALLY
DONE THAT, HE'S OUTRAGED.
>> WE NOW HAVE AMERICANS STUCK
IN AFGHANISTAN.
THE TALIBAN IN CHARGE WITH MORE
WEAPONRY THAN THEY'VE EVER HAD
IN THE PAST AND A BORDER THAT IS
OPEN.
>> IT'S NOT EVEN A GOOD ACTOR.
AND WE HAVE AND A BORDER THAT IS
OPEN.
THE GOP GOING AFTER A PRESIDENT
FOR CARRYING OUT THE DEAL THE
FORMER GUY CUT IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
>> AFTER 20 YEARS OF WAR, JOE
BIDEN OR WHOEVER IS TELLING HIM
WHAT TO DO NOWADAYS MADE THE
TALIBAN STRONGER THAN EVER.
>> SO, WE, YOU KNOW, THIS NEWS
NETWORK, WE LIKE FACTS HERE.
LET'S REMEMBER IT WAS THE
PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION THAT
BEGAN THE PROCESS OF NEGOTIATING
WITH THE TALIBAN.
IT WAS THE FORMER GUY WHO
SECRETLY PLANNED TO MEET WITH
THE TALIBAN AT CAMP DAVID RIGHT
BEFORE THE ANNIVERSARY OF 9/11.
IT WAS THE FORMER GUY WHO SIGNED
A PEACE TREATY WITH THE TALIBAN.
LET ME SAY IT AGAIN.
IT WAS THE FORMER GUY WHO SIGNED
A PEACE TREATY WITH THE TALIBAN
WHO BRAGGED ABOUT HIS PHONE CALL
WITH THE MAN WHO NOW LEADS THE
TALIBAN IN AFGHANISTAN WHO WAS
RELEASED FROM PRISON AT THE
REQUEST OF, WAIT FOR IT, THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
WHOSE SECRETARY OF STATE MET
WITH HIM LAST FALL SO YEAH, WHO
MADE THE TALIBAN STRONGER?
WHO WAS IT WHO MADE THE TALIBAN
STRONGER?
ARE YOU LISTENING TO ME?
WHO CUT THE DEALS?
WHO MET WITH?
WHO HAD THE PHONE CALLS?
LIKE I SAID, IN THE MIDDLE OF
ALL OF THIS, THE PRESIDENT IS
DEALING WITH ONE CRISIS AFTER
ANOTHER HERE AT HOME.
MORE THAN A MILLION PEOPLE ALONG
THE GULF COAST WHO SURVIVED ONE
OF THE MOST POWERFUL STORMS EVER
TO HIT THE UNITED STATES NOW
FACING THE POSSIBILITY OF WEEKS,
EVEN UP TO A MONTH WITHOUT
POWER.
THE NATIONAL WEATHER SERVICE
ISSUING HEAT ADVISORIES AND I
CAN TELL YOU FIRSTHAND SUMMERS
IN LOUISIANA ARE BRUTAL.
BRUTALLY HOT AND MUGGY AND
DANGEROUS.
PEOPLE LINING UP FOR FOOD AND
WATER.
WE'RE ONLY GETTING THE FULL
PICTURE NOW HOW BAD THINGS ARE
IN THE WAKE OF HURRICANE IDA.
FIVE STORM RELATED DEATHS
REPORTED.
THE GOVERNOR OF MY HOME STATE OF
LOUISIANA TELLING PEOPLE WHO
FLED THE STORM DON'T COME BACK
YET.
NEW ORLEANS IS UNDER A CURFEW
TONIGHT AS DESPERATE PEOPLE ARE
STILL PICKING UP THE PIECES AND
THEN THERE IS THE DESTRUCTIVE
EFFECT OF THE BIG LIE, STILL
BEING FELT ALL ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY WITH THE ASSAULT ON
VOTING RIGHTS, WHICH IS NOTHING
LESS THAN A PLAN TO GIVE THE GOP
THE POWER TO OVERTURN THE NEXT
ELECTION IF THEY DON'T LIKE THE
RESULTS.
THE BIG LIE THAT FUELED ONE OF
THE DARKEST DAYS IN AMERICAN
HISTORY.
JANUARY 6th.
YOU KNOW THAT'S WHEN BLOOD
THIRSTY RIOTERS TRIED TO OVER
THROW OUR FREE AND FAIR
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION HUNTING
LAWMAKERS FORCED TO RUN FOR
THEIR LIVES INCLUDING THE VICE
PRESIDENT.
BEATING PLIROLICE, AMERICAN HER
TRYING TO DEFEND OUR SEAT, THE
SEAT OF DEMOCRACY.
WE ALL SAW WHAT HAPPENED ON THAT
HORRIBLE DAY.
IT PLAYED OUT LIVE, MUCH OF IT
AND SAW THE REST OF IT, THE BODY
WORN CAMERAS FROM POLICE
OFFICERS, THE OTHER VIDEO THAT
PEOPLE RECORDED HAPPILY GETTING
THEM IN TROUBLE.
WE CAN NEVER FORGET WHAT WE SAW.
IT'S UTTERLY DISGRACEFUL A
UNITED STATES CONGRESSMAN THERE
ON THAT DAY IS NOT ONLY STILL
SPREADING THE BIG LIE OF BOGUS
ELECTION FRAUD BUT TALKING ABOUT
TAKING UP ARMS AGAINST HIS
FELLOW AMERICANS.
>> IF OUR ELECTION SYSTEMS
CONTINUE TO BE RIGGED AND
STOLEN, IT WILL LEAD TO ONE
PLACE AND IT'S BLOODSHED AND I
WILL TELL YOU AS MUCH AS I AM
WILLING TO DEFEND OUR LIBERTY AT
ALL COSTS, THERE IS NOTHING THAT
I WOULD DREAD DOING MORE THAN
HAVING TO PICK UP ARMS AGAINST A
FELLOW AMERICAN AND THE WAY WE
CAN HAVE RESOURCE AGAINST THAT
IS IF WE ALL PASSIONATELY DEMAND
WE HAVE ELECTION SECURITY IN ALL
50 STATES.
>> THESE PEOPLE.
I MEAN, NO SHAME, NONE.
MADISON DOESN'T SEEM TO
UNDERSTAND WORDS MATTER, WORDS
LIKE RIGGED, STOLEN, TAKING UP
ARMS AGAINST A FELLOW AMERICAN.
HE DOESN'T SEEM TO UNDERSTAND
THAT THOSE ARE THE KINDS OF
WORDS THE LIES I SHOULD SAY THAT
FUEL THE INSURRECTION AT THE
UNITED STATES CAPITOL IN THE
FIRST PLACE.
MAYBE HE DOES UNDERSTAND.
AFTER ALL, HE WAS RIGHT THERE AT
THE RALLY BEFORE THE CAPITOL WAS
ATTACKED.
RIGHT THERE SPEWING LIES.
>> THE DEMOCRATS WITH ALL THE
FRAUD THEY HAVE DONE IN THIS
ELE
ELECTION, THE REPUBLICANS HIDING
AND NOT FIGHTING, THEY ARE
TRYING TO SILENCE YOUR VOICE.
>> THAT NIGHT HE VOTED TO
OVERTURN THE ELECTION RESULTS
EVEN AFTER THE VERY REAL
VIOLENCE AND BLOODSHED THAT WE
ALL SAW THAT DAY.
CAN YOU IMAGINE VOTING TO
OVERTURN THE ELECTION AFTER
HAVING WITNESSES AND POSSIBLY
HAVING YOUR SAFETY AND YOUR LIFE
JEOPARDIZED?
WELL, THEIR SAFETY WAS
JEOPARDIZED, THEIR LIVES WERE
JEOPARDIZED, NOT POSSIBLY.
WHAT DO YOU EXPECT FROM THE
CONGRESSMAN THAT JUST WEEKS
BEFORE THE VIOLENCE AT THE
CAPITOL SAID THIS.
>> I'M ENCOURAGING YOU, PLEASE,
GET ON THE PHONE.
CALL YOUR CONGRESSMAN AND FEEL
FREE, YOU CAN LIGHTLY THREATEN
THEM AND SAY YOU KNOW WHAT?
IF YOU DON'T START SUPPORTING
ELECTION INTEGRITY, I'M COMING
AFTER YOU, MADISON CAWTHORN IS
COMING AFTER YOU.
EVERYONE IS COMING AFTER YOU.
>> YOU CAN LIGHTLY THREATEN
THEM.
CONGRESSMAN CAWTHORN'S
SPOKESPERSON SAID HE WAS CLEARLY
ADVOCATING FOR VIOLENCE TO NOT
OCCUR PICKING UP ARMS AGAINST A
F
FELLOW AMERICAN.
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT.
BUT WORDS MATTER.
WORDS THAT SPREAD LIES, THE LIES
THAT I HAVE SAID BEFORE ARE
KILLING US AND OUR DEMOCRACY.
CASE IN POINT, HERE IT IS.
REMEMBER THAT SCHOOL BOARD
MEETING IN FLORIDA YESTERDAY?
THE ONE WHERE A FISTFIGHT BROKE
OUT OVER THE COUNTY'S NEW MASK
MANDATE HAPPENED CAUGHT LIVE ON
TELEVISION.
THERE IS MORE.
MUCH MORE.
WHAT HAPPENED OUTSIDE IS REALLY
NOTHING IN COMPARISON TO WHAT
WENT ON INSIDE.
>> THESE ARE DEMONIC ENTITIES
AND ALL THE SCHOOL BOARDS IN THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA AND ALL
OF US CHRISTIANS WILL BE
STICKING TOGETHER TO TAKE THEM
ALL OUT.
MASKS DON'T WORK.
THESE DOCTORS THAT SIT UP HERE
THAT WERE SNEERING AT US AND
LOOKING AT US LIKE WE'RE SCUM
BAGS NEED TO GO BACK TO
[ BLEEP ] MEDICAL SCHOOL.
>> WOW.
SHE USED CHRISTIAN AND THAT
WORD --
[ LAUGHTER ]
IN THE SAME BREATH.
BEING A CHRISTIAN IS NOT JUST
SAYING I'M A CHRISTIAN.
IT'S ACTUALLY ABIDING BY THE
PRINCIPLES OF WHAT BEING A
CHRISTIAN IS SUPPOSED TO BE
ABOUT.
YOU JUST CAN'T DO WHATEVER YOU
WANT AND SAY WHATEVER YOU WANT
AND CALL PEOPLE TALKING ABOUT
AND SAY F WORDS AND ALL THAT AND
SAY I'M A CHRISTIAN.
I DON'T WANT TO WEAR A MASK.
I DON'T WANT TO HELP MY FELLOW
PERSON.
I DON'T WANT TO DO ON TO OTHERS.
I DON'T WANT TO SAVE OTHER
PEOPLE'S LIVES BUT I'M A
CHRISTIAN.
COME ON, MAN.
REALLY?
THIS JUST GOES TO SHOW YOU HOW
DIVIDED AMERICA IS ON EVERY
SINGLE LEVEL.
WE CAN'T EVEN AGREE ON A SIMPLE
THING LIKE MASKS TO KEEP OUR
CHILDREN SAFE, THE LEAST OF
THESE.
I'M A CHRISTIAN.
I WANT TO KEEP CHILDREN SAFE.
MY CHILD, MY DECISION.
WHAT ABOUT THAT OT